good morning millennials
welcome back to the toast happy Thursday
I am so excited to be joined by a
co-host who was so heavily requested the
giggly girlies are here it's Paige
Disorder so excited thank you thank you
for coming no I am wait sorry can you
move your mic closer to your mouth yeah
I actually dressed a little comfy today
because I feel like I do my best gossip
comfortable like this is what happens
people come because you've been on a few
times and every time you come you stunt
on these hoes with your outfits and I'm
here like in my toast merch and leggings
and sneakers and this happens with
Taylor strucker it happens with Shannon
Ford and honestly I'm like I need to
step my [__] up wait can we talk about
how good Taylor Striker has been looking
I'm obsessed like I always Envision her
as like just like a rich woman yes she's
giving like full rich woman no she looks
so good I'm so happy for her every time
she comes on the toast all we do is talk
about his own bag like
I could find a way to bring up those 100
everyday life I was gonna get in a
minute it's a life-changing drug Taylor
and I are kind of like the face of it
or like the body of it I guess I would
say and she looks so good yeah she does
and so I decided to like get my best my
Sunday Best out for you you look amazing
you're kind of raising the bar for
everyone constantly I appreciate that no
we appreciate you I just try and I do it
for the girls for the girls and the gays
I do it for the girls and the gays and I
have to say you get so we get so many
requests whenever we do maternity leave
like bring Paige back and one of my
favorite like because I'm like a sleuth
and I'm annoying like one of my favorite
things to do is like bring people on the
toes like see other episodes before I'm
like because everybody like acts on
social media like I'm so great no I got
it but it's interesting you know to see
who translates the numbers don't lie
they don't and I wanted to tell you the
last time you were here I think you were
maybe in the top three yeah and Hannah
the giggly girls love you because I feel
like the toast girlies and the giggly
girlies have equal amount of like mental
health issues yeah we're all the same
yeah and I'm so glad to be catching you
in this time of year because like you're
kind of everywhere first of all you're
on multiple reality shows so you're of
course we know her queen of Southern I
mean of summer house yep but you're also
now like like a girly on Southern Charm
uh and I tried really hard to like not
be a girly on Southern Charm I was like
I don't I don't I have my own thing
group of people who are crazy that I'm
dealing with their drama I don't know if
I could take on a whole second another
crew but then things happen and I can't
shut up and both the shows that you're
on right now are having like Monumental
Seasons well we haven't seen summer
house yet but of course we all know Carl
and Lindsay yeah now on Southern Charm
Taylor and Austin like was that like
crazy to you or did you like see that
coming it was crazy because I in real
time like was finding things out so like
an episode is gonna come out where like
I find out
like the Taylor and like Olivia of it
all and my face I'm just like shocked
shocking no it's crazy I feel like it's
the beauty and Jackie we're having this
conversation it's kind of the equivalent
it's like a scandal of Southern Charms
yeah but the only thing is it's like
Ariana was the victim in Scandal and
she's like a sympathetic victim people
like aren't going to be out here crying
for Shep he's just like not made himself
like a really sympathetic character
right right right and also because he
cheated right so it's like he's not like
a scorn and they were broken up but it's
really the and he's a man
wait I love that you said that mention
it right they shouldn't because I don't
think they should be in the Arts like at
all interesting we also don't believe
that they should have cooking shows
that's disgusting which is an art in and
of itself but they shouldn't have them
they shouldn't and then Cody Riggs
became on the toast yesterday and he's
on this like promo tour for his book and
he was like I heard you think men can
right and I was like well first of all
you're gay so like you're obviously
better you're dead yeah he said he
agreed yeah and then I was like I was
mostly talking about like fiction
storytelling yeah can't tell stories no
they unless it's their own right like
they can't gossip no at all no better
because I was gonna say it's been a good
gossiper no mostly and this is where we
differ he like doesn't care I'm like
what is that like not caring about if
you told me that like a crazy thing that
happened to your home friend who I've
never met I would think it was the
craziest thing and you would have a
dynamite follow-up question of course
and then I would find a way to like
connect I'm like oh I know her friend
from college yeah you know and then
you're down a rabbit hole so in bed
doesn't care but Ben like gets good
information because Ben's like this
affable guy yeah and everybody who meets
him like kind of just like trusts him
yeah he does have that like where I'll
tell you my whole life story we call it
the benefact yeah he can get anything
like people love Ben he's such a good
like networker connector like if I
wanted tickets to the Super Bowl he
would have like I said if you've been a
few days ago I'm like I want um to go to
the Jets game on Sunday yeah and because
they think Taylor Swift is going to be
there and it came out yesterday that she
actually is going to be there so like
the prices for tickets are like so crazy
uh Ben got two different options he said
which one do you want wait yeah I'm
obsessed with that you ever need
anything called men he'll do it okay Ben
Ben's really smart he um
he like his a form of currency of his is
like favors he's like oh I just did a
favor for this guy so let me ask him for
that wait that's so Mafia I love it it's
called The benefactor and I think we
could all really learn from him yeah I
think so too yeah and he calls himself
Ben stopper celebrity but like the
reason why you want to hear the funny
story I forget I think we were in
Portugal and we were talking about how
like such ugly pictures come up of us on
Google yeah and he was trying to find
this one that that we like that he like
hates so much but he couldn't find it
and then like the conversation moved on
and he pulled out his phone and we all
look over at his phone he had been
looking for the photo and he searched
Ben soffer's celebrity
and we like roasted him endlessly but
now it kind of stuck BSC Benson that's
amazing yeah and he honestly is a
celebrity I wish I had half the
confidence any man I've ever met it's so
true it's kind of wild sometimes it's
true I'm just it's enviable yeah but
yeah men can't write they shouldn't be
in the Arts they shouldn't have cooking
shows and Cody Rigsby said yesterday too
they shouldn't be Super Bowl performers
but we made we made the exception for
Usher because he's got Charisma Cody
called him like a [__] and I agree but
don't you feel like Taylor Swift is
gunning for that position next year so I
could literally write a dissertation on
Taylor Swift in the Super Bowl for many
years it was the Pepsi halftime show and
Taylor had done like a very long I want
to say like five year contract with Diet
Coke that had a non-compete and I think
it had a non-compete for many years
after so she wasn't eligible okay got it
okay I didn't know this you are my
Taylor Swift goober I know can I just
say you made my Taylor Swift experience
yes I wanted to talk about that we went
to the Taylor Swift concert together and
Craig was like hyped up he's like I'm a
big Taylor Swift fan and like halfway
through the concert he turns and he's
like why don't I know any of these songs
I didn't know one song Maybe I'm not
like a Taylor Swift it's just like a
really long concert so yeah you know the
hits like five or ten but there's 40
songs no when you leaned over and said
if you have to pee you should go now was
just one of my face I was like oh my God
I would have missed an amazing part
you're like she's gonna talk for a long
five minutes and you can go to the
bathroom now and that was great it was a
good time to go to the bathroom you
nailed it so
um we're gonna talk about Taylor Swift
any questions you might have oh but so
that's why she didn't do it because of
Diet Coke then it switched to Apple
music now I think it's only like year
two of Apple music but she's been on the
era's tour so it doesn't really you know
work with her schedule got it got it so
I do believe it has to be coming up yeah
in the next few years there's a few
people who it's like why haven't you
done it Carrie Underwood why haven't you
done it pink
Kelly Clarkson
because in my head they've all done it
no I know but then it's like when you
look back it's like Coldplay's done it
three times Bruno Mars has done it two
times Beyonce's done it two times they
like they recycle certain people but
they don't bring in new talents and
doesn't Carrie sing the song yes that's
what we were talking about on Monday she
does the like the NFL Sunday Night
Football like yeah yeah
Sunday night like she's part of the
family yeah it makes no sense that makes
zero sense so we talked about southern
charm we need to talk about
summer housing not summer house breaking
the internet when it came out that Carla
Lindsay broke up and there's so much
confusion about like what actually I'm
sure you're limited why you can say I'm
not gonna push you because like you have
a contract and I honor that you know
like what the [__] is going on okay it's
so interesting because this summer
definitely very different from any other
summer we've had did you get out of bed
I went out every weekend look at you
like literally dancing on tables wasn't
as fun as laying in your bed
like pros and cons for sure like I
definitely thought about my bed a lot
and was like the first to go yeah
um we had a great time this summer to
the point where we actually said like
the last day of filming like wow what's
already something gonna be like because
it was copacetic yeah it was copacetic I
mean obviously there was some drama but
it wasn't like so deep and so dark that
we were like I'll never speak to that
person again it was like chill drama
that like normal people have and we were
like there's just gonna be nothing it's
gonna be nice and then literally 48
hours later we were like pardon how did
you find out
the internet like everyone else because
like it wasn't no one was there besides
them too no one was yeah no one was
there I don't even really know like
detailed details
um I just know I found out through the
internet texted Amanda and was like did
you see this on like I forget what it
even was everywhere yeah literally
everywhere and she was like call me and
we're just one of my favorite texts
because when people call me I'm like go
away yeah but when somebody when like
I'm asking a juicy question they're like
you need to call me that's exciting I'm
like let me get comfy you know let me
change let me take my makeup off yeah
let me get my I like my phone holder so
I can like talk with my hands I keep one
on my nightstand
that is the best no it's the best yeah
or when someone says wait I forgot to
tell you this like literally gets or
when you ask a simple gossip question
you get a voice memo in return me and
Hannah are big voice memo people okay
influencers love voice memos I love that
because I feel like I don't trust anyone
yeah so I don't ever want to type
anything I don't trust myself like I
don't need to put this in writing Hannah
I know I like he but I also like hearing
certain people the way they say things
intonation yeah it's just different
uh-huh like if Craig sent me a voice
note I'd be like you could have texted
us totally but like if your girlfriend
sends you one you're like okay this is
Juicy especially someone like Amanda
because like her and Kyle like really
are like like a
what's the word I'm looking for Jackie
always finds the words I'm looking for
like where they're like the control room
like yeah they have they have Kyle they
have Amanda they have the girls they
have the guys like it's kind of like the
center yeah Communication Center they're
the nucleus nucleus so like getting that
I need to call you from her specifically
changes the game because here's the
other thing Kyle also is notoriously so
bad at gossip but yet gets it all yep so
like we're when we ask him questions
he's like oh I don't know I didn't ask
it's always the people who get the
information who don't appreciate it I've
actually been training Craig so hard
that now when he's places without me
he'll text me and be like don't worry
I'm I'm writing it all in my notes like
what's happening so Jackie does that
with me because I love to pass it but I
have the worst memory yeah and like I
love a cocktail right you know right so
you're a simple girl if I'm going to
dinner with like somebody who has good
gossip or like a dinner with like
someone crazy who I just like need to
tell Jackie everything they did like I
will go to the bathroom and start
anything down like I'm like I have to
pee and then just like four things you
have to it's important because if you
forget something and then it comes to
you days later the gossip just doesn't
hit the same as like that next morning
no we're bad yeah I know well like it
was just Yom Kippur yep and like you're
supposed to kind of look at your whole
life and be like what could I be doing
better and it's actually like a really
big sin this is your New Year right it's
right after New Year it's like a day of
atonement it's like a serious day you're
supposed to it's when you're like you're
it's like when God plans out the year
like you're gonna be in the book of life
you know you have to like act right on
your own people yeah and just to be
self-reflective yeah and it's a big
thing in Judaism it's called Lush and
horror it means like to speak evil okay
but I think like the translate like I'm
not 100 sure like if gossiping and like
exchanging information like with like a
sister or best friend is considered
because we're not speaking evil we're
just sharing information you're saying
facts back and forth to each other it's
just a conversation well you don't want
us to talk
what are people talking about if not
each other that I don't know and here's
the other thing when people are like oh
my God she's such a gossip or like I
hate gossip then you must have a really
boring friend group no and that's the
thing like if you're like a part of a
friend group and there's one person who
like you know is better than everyone in
Roblox that person is immediately boring
and we're talking about you right
because you won't participate you're the
one that's being talked about it's a
self-fulfilling prophecy yeah it's just
well it's just a crazy time to be Paige
disordbo giggly Squad everywhere live
tour podcast killing it summer house
Southern Charm
Craig is a full-time job
um he's really good though he pitched
the first ball at the Orioles game I saw
the other night and he was a basket of
nerves I'm sure like you would have
never known but he was so nervous I feel
like for a man it's actually like girls
like they throw like a girl like you
could throw a dub and it's like so cute
and I was trying to make him feel better
and I was like look I genuinely have
never seen someone throw the first pitch
like if I'm at a game like I've never
cared I've never looked up I'm getting a
drink I was like no one's watching and
you know Craig he didn't love that he
was like but I feel like people are hard
I was like no no as many people as you
want to watch are watching so true you
can make the case you're gonna be fine
and how did he do he did great that's so
exciting but I wouldn't know otherwise I
know that like you're supposed to make
it over home plate like that's a good
one yeah he did and so we felt good
that's amazing we got the content it's
also low-key hard it's really far it's
really fun
before he went out to like do it he's
turned to me and he was like never stop
recording
I was like this
just the best moment I met I was like
you got it I guess for a guy that's like
being invited to like Fashion Week no
that was I could only like think of it
in those terms yeah yeah so it was a big
moment for him that's huge yeah and how
was Paige and Craig like I'm just
obsessed Paige and crack are doing good
where are you living now
um so I'm in New York like honestly I'm
in New York June July August September
for summer house for summer house and
then like September just seems to be a
busy month in New York it is U.S open
Fashion Week yeah just like I can't miss
the turn the queen of fashion no did you
go to the US Open I did and I feel like
tennis is having a real moment I know I
was obsessed but you also like live with
Hannah right and Hannah's like tennis
obsessed so it could appear that way but
I'm here to let you know like in the
real world too it is
Hannah gets some really Niche gossip oh
so like Hannah always gets the tennis
girly gossip and it's like I don't know
any of these people but I'm I think I
know what I'm talking about into it I
think I know what you're talking about
and we should talk about it after okay
we'll talk about it after and she also
will get stand-up comedy gossip oh
that's interesting because it's very
Niche like a small circle very small
circle so I'm very invested in a lot of
people's lives that I don't know their
last name I love that and that's great
for me because you're collecting
information at this point for a later
date oh I'd love that we'll have to chat
later yeah well today you're here to
serve one purpose yeah and that's to be
actually too like to be your fabulous
Page Self but to join me in discussing
the Fast Five what current pop culture
story is like are you dying over I mean
I the Taylor Swift Travis Kelsey is just
like sweeping the nation do you think
Travis Kelsey's hot I do
he described him yesterday as corn fed
and I thought that was like the perfect
way to describe it okay this is gonna be
unpopular and I'm not and I'm not coming
for him whatsoever and I think
um crazy you're in the NFL so talented
good for you so hot tall
there's just something about him that
like when he was saying that he went to
a Taylor Swift show he made a bracelet
with his phone number on it and he was
like a little butt hurt he she didn't
see him after get a grip I got the ick
kind of immediately I completely agree
not enough people are talking about who
he's he's like extremely cringy yeah you
were making fun of him endlessly because
when he invited Taylor to the show he
went on Pat McAfee and he was asked
about it and he said I told Taylor this
is okay this is the words he actually
said and then I'll tell you how he said
it okay he said I told Taylor you know I
saw you rock the stage at Arrowhead why
don't you see come see me rock the stage
at Arrowhead that's how he invited her
to the show but when he regurgitated his
own words on Pat McAfee he said I said
listen Taylor
foreign
I saw you rock the stage at Herod why
don't you come see me rock the stage at
Arrowhead it was ick no but she also
rocked the stage at Arrowhead is it
Arrowhead yeah okay on her own sold it
out you're out there with a hundred guys
don't equate it there's empty seats
don't equate the two you are not the
same like when I saw the meme like it's
so cute of Taylor to go check on the
arena while they turned it into the Mojo
Jojo house I lost it I was like that's
amazing it's so perfectly put yeah like
she's doing the most and we're supposed
to be impressed by this like football
team and there's something about like a
really hot guy who and I'm sure he's
lovely and very nice sure I love you
like have to say that what are you about
to say I'm sure but there's something
about a really hot guy who tries to act
like oh I'm just like I'm just like
really down to earth I'm just like a
nice guy like I'm just like from the
Midwest like
no okay I love that because I've met so
many of them where I'm like wait but
you're actually one of the most
diabolical people I've ever met I think
like a universal rule is that if you
have to say you're down to earth you are
not
like the girlies that are out here being
like I'm so nice or like I am a girls
girl which I feel like I do say that a
lot but like girls girl is different
it's like okay well if you have to tell
me I feel like you're lying no what are
you hiding yeah what's underneath that
like if you get along with everyone
everyone will just know right like you
don't have to say it it's just like it
is yeah I agree like people who would
claim like the salt of the earth
something's wrong no something is wrong
because you know you never hear his
brother Jason Kelsey say he's you know
Down to Earth because he actually right
because I feel like he genuinely is like
he he's not thirsty he does his work he
goes family yeah like he's someone who's
just proving that he's down to earth
without saying it here's the other thing
about that what's the other thing I very
much believe that like
you have a type yeah especially as a guy
like yes a woman is like every guy's
child they'll take whatever they can get
a hole is a hole
right like
some type of an aesthetic there Taylor
especially
I feel like women are more or like your
personality right like Taylor dated a
million different looks and Vibes but
we're different like we can adapt no
because we like see underneath and by
the way I really feel like for women Me
and Jackie always say this like a man
becomes attractive to you based on their
personality yes you could say arbitrary
arbitrarily like oh that guy's ugly but
like when you know him a woman sees him
as beautiful like really like they get
hotter oh for sure and him and his
ex-girlfriends I mean it so different
couldn't it couldn't be more different
that's why I like the whole thing and
that's what I was saying and people I
love Taylor and I'm championing this
relationship like now I'm on board but I
think it's important to think critically
and be like he is really thirsty I think
so too like the whole friendship
bracelet thing it's too much like
honestly Craig and I have only been
dating for two years and he dated like
one girl before me who had blonde hair
and I won't let it go that's interesting
you know I'm like but you like blondes
and he's like it gets really mad at me
that's a fair point I'm like well proof
isn't
I think about that too and I always
think like
it's so normal for someone to like date
and marry someone who had multiple
girlfriends before me and Ben met when
we were 18 so like neither of us really
had a girlfriend yeah then had like one
girlfriend actually know her she's so
lovely and do you randomly like bring
her up I know and they like literally
dated for like maybe two months in like
freshman year of college but to me it's
like my only frame of preference and I
will never get over it I can't imagine
like dating someone meeting someone at
like a normal age like 25 or 30. yeah
and then they have like five girlfriends
oh no I'm every girl Craig's even spoken
to I'm liked it that's your girlfriend
like why don't you text your girlfriend
no calling people who Ben has met one
time his girlfriend is my favorite
activity I'm gonna start doing it it's
so funny and or whatever Ben's like five
minutes late he said he was supposed to
be home at 7 15 last night he got a
woman like 7 45 and I was like oh how's
your girlfriend yeah like what in my
regards I
use like a makeup artist one time and
the only other person I knew was like a
girl that like Craig dated and I was
like oh I'm like using this new makeup
artist like she used to do your
girlfriend and he was like who and I'm
like because he's had too many you know
like hold on you know what I'm talking
about for sure it's also a small circle
of like yeah
LOL well we're going to dive into the
fast five pages here to join me so Paige
I just have one last question for you
okay are you ready for the past five
stories that you need to know I am thank
God today's episode of the toast is
brought to you by State Farm
specifically the State Farm personal
price plan they help you create a plan
that gives you options so you get an
affordable price and it comes with a ton
of benefits like the coverage you want a
policy that helps cover what's important
to you and most importantly an
affordable price just for you because
after all life is just better when you
can personalize your experiences and so
many things in life are so personal
comedy food insurance and State Farm
gets that because State Farm is Toasty
as hell so think about it like this what
are your music playlists podcast feeds
social media Scrolls all have in common
well they're a reflection of you so we
all know my social media is full of
Taylor Swift conspiracy theories it's
lately full of like a ton of football
because I'm so athletic Jackies are so
different you know she's a rails girl so
we're different even though how similar
are we we still have such specific and
different needs and insurance is even
more specific than that and that's what
the State Farm personal price plan has
in common it gives you options that help
you personalize your coverage so that
you can protect what you care about most
and most importantly at an affordable
price just for you so you'll be able to
see more of yourself in everything you
love like a good neighbor
stay from is there see I personalized
the slogan because like I have an
amazing voice and Jackie doesn't so
we're so different
call or go to statefarm.com today to
create your State Farm personal price
plan prices vary by state option
selected by customer availability and
eligibility may vary let me just do that
one more time because I didn't like love
the one I lasted like a good neighbor
State Farm is there gorgeous thank you
State Farm for sponsoring today's
episode today's episode is also brought
to you by Thrive Market Thrive Market is
our go-to for all of our grocery and
household essentials and the convenience
of getting everything online then
quickly shipped to my doorstep is a huge
Time Saver Jackie as always was like the
first one in the family to really Rave
about Thrive market and she was 100
right I've discovered so many good
snacks from Thrive market and really
when you're looking for like clean
snacks when you're looking for clean
household essentials like you know uh
kitchen cleaners they have everything
you need from top to bottom and it all
gets delivered to your house which is
just so fabulous you have to Lug like a
thousand grocery bags out of your house
like make two trips in a pair of heels
that you left by the door so as a Thrive
Market member we are saving money on
every single grocery order on average
receiving over 30 percent every time on
top of the savings they have a deal age
it changes daily where you can get like
cash back on a ton of Brands and they
have a price match guarantee so not only
does thrive Market save me money but
they also save us time instead of
reading a bunch of label ingredients in
the grocery store we can use their
filters on their website that suit our
needs so whether you're looking for
certified gluten-free snacks low sugar
Alternatives non-toxic cleaning you can
basically curate your own shopping
experience with the click of a button
and it's made with the highest quality
ingredients and sourcing methods I have
to say the way I've discovered so many
good snacks from Thrive market like
Annie's makes cheese puffs who knew that
I only know that because Jackie had them
in her house to give to Harry but she
couldn't because I ate them all
um and with Thrive Market you're also
helping a family in need so when you
join
they have a one-for-one membership
matching program so you basically join
and they give and it's fabulous your
needs are met they're helping people
there's no reason not to be using Thrive
Market in my opinion so join in on the
savings with Thrive market today get 30
off your first order plus a free 60 gift
when you go to thrivemarket.com the
toast that'll be 30 off your first order
plus a free 60 gift at Thrive
market.com slash the toast
thrivemarket.com the toast all right
some Taylor Swift news obviously Travis
Kelsey but this actually isn't about
that it came out yesterday that she has
loaned Sophie Turner and her kids a New
York City Apartment during the bitter
legal battle with Joe Jonas so the
Superstar singer has been by Sophie
Turner's side ever since the actress
split from Joe Jonas came to light she's
taking her to dinner keeping her
entertained I'm in her breakup but now
page six hears that Swift has even
loaned Sophie Turner a stunning
apartment in her own downtown New York
City neighborhood that the actress and
her children can live in while Turner
and Jonas get their complex custody
Arrangements ironed out so apparently
she keeps a Tribeca PAD as an investment
property but is handed Keys over to the
Game of Thrones Star as a temporary home
and says that Sophie Turner has been
spotted settling into the famously Chic
neighborhood checking out some of the
local Comfort Suits food spots and she
was photographed yesterday I think like
handing off the kids to Joe because she
came out in like sweatpants I mean like
a sweatshirt and shorts and put all the
kids in the car and then wave goodbye
wow and it's like in Tribeca these
paparazzi photos are like incredibly
intimate like so crazy to think they
live like down the street no I know
that's what's so crazy about New York
and why starting today like I'm going
out every night and I'm going to the
Jets game because one of my like
favorite activities is to get dressed
and stay alert yeah and just like look
around for Taylor
you and Margo haven't met her I know or
like at least been at the same I know
event as her like it doesn't seem I was
like
you guys I was at um the Eros tour yeah
and she was there too
I have one time gotten like um a package
from her yeah with like a handwritten
note with merch like but then I never
heard from her again do you think she
wrote it
um no right but I choose to believe that
she did okay my one question that I feel
like you'll know were Sophie and Taylor
friends prior like when Joe and Sophie
got together were Taylor and Sophie
already friends or they became friends
they became friends I believe when the
relationship with Joe started especially
because that Fearless was being
re-released and that's all about Joe so
like Taylor brought them into the fold
she posted about the song so she was
cool with Joe always cool and Taylor's a
huge Game of Thrones fan so they had met
because Taylor was obsessed with Game of
Thrones and I believe um there's a song
about Arya and
Queen Sansa I think it's end game is
about that okay or some one of the songs
like Taylor like always writes about
like things in popular culture she's
written songs about like different
movies and books and she's written music
about Game of Thrones she loves it I'm a
big Sophie Turner fan me too and I think
like I'm loving the way this is turning
out because when the divorce news first
came out it was like clearly a narrative
from Camp Jonas and it was like really
anti-selfie anti-mom and it was actually
anti-woman no it was so anti-woman it
was like how dare she go out and at 27.
right and like she's British right like
they there's I feel like British
culturally socializing is different like
their drinking habits are a little
different and yeah I'm just and nobody
believed it that's what I loved they
were like oh we're getting fed all this
information team Sophie everyone's so in
on like PR stunts now I know we're kind
of too smart like you can't really pull
one over on the internet anymore and
it's interesting being on reality TV
because like when things will happen
like okay perfect example is Carl and
Lindsay breaking up yeah like but no
one's seen anything so it's like you
can't keep even keep a secret no till
like the season comes out and so people
are already like picked their sides pick
their sides like sleuths like all these
blogs who have really no connections but
like making stuff up like right it's
true so by the time the season comes out
like you kind of [__] sometimes but
sometimes it is obviously like it's not
you like it is funny to see certain
rumors yes like there was one rumor that
Carl like got a girl pregnant and she
was like crying in a bathroom somewhere
from what I don't know and like knowing
Carl like no yeah but when I read that I
was like interesting crazy and that's
hilarious it is I also love about this
story I feel like there are so many
moments in like pop culture like Taylor
Swift is kind of like a bankroll for
women yeah like remembering she paid all
of Kesha's legal's bills against Dr Luke
no I didn't yeah because like Kesha's
entire like discography she was sweet
that's so nice she gave her 250 000 to
pay her legal fees that's like
us getting a cab do you know what I mean
it's like oh I'll get you your Uber home
it's nothing to her but like to Kesha
she was probably drowning in lingle
Bells she wasn't able to work because
her work was owned by this man who she
was accusing of sexual harassment and
like
it was like this terrible situation and
here comes Queen Taylor taking care of
the bill she's giving home to the
displaced like she's literally like
saving women in crisis she boosts our
economy she literally actually did like
the GDP is up like even they were doing
all the stats for last Sunday like the
amount of people watching the amount of
jerseys like is he
did you put him on the map no like I
wonder if he does think at all like wow
I should have given her like a cut on
the pod on the podcast he has a podcast
and it came out yesterday and they had
recorded after Sunday's game and they
spoke very little about Taylor he was
basically just like we had fun I'm so
glad she came I'm gonna keep it private
um but his brother did bring up the fact
that his jersey sales went up 400 yeah
like he's aware like that's crazy no
like that's her power yeah you'd love to
see women in power being powerful I I
just I'm very here for her like
everything she's doing right now me too
for like everyone and she's doing good
work like home giving Sophie and her
kids a home I'm sure like there's a
reason why Sophie has to be in New York
well she's filming a movie well she was
that's what the whole the divorce
paperwork that came out she filed the
lawsuit against Joe and it was like
filled with interesting information that
someone who I love on Tick Tock the talk
of Shame she read it and like did all
the work first this is when she was like
I want the kids to go back to yeah so
they had agreed at the beginning of this
year or the in December of last year
we're gonna live in the UK okay so they
bought a house they're renovating it and
then they started renting a house to
live in until the renovations were done
they enrolled the kids in schools got
them doctors like made all this thing
and then when the summer came he was
leaving for tour okay and she was going
to film something until September and
she said you take the kids on tour I'll
be working till September and then come
September I'll come pick them up on tour
bring them back to the UK and we'll live
in our new house together but that never
happened because in August he filed for
divorce
okay the thing that I can't figure out
and I don't understand when he filed for
divorce when she was at that concert two
days earlier like we haven't yes like
why is now talking about that now
looking back the first few days are
filled with questions
because did she not know that he was
like not gonna let them live in the UK
yeah like what like why would she have
gone to the concert if they were at such
odds that he was like to the point where
he was filing for divorce that next day
yeah I don't know maybe
um and I don't know because I don't have
children but like maybe the kids really
wanted to go to the concert and like as
a mom like you just do what the kids
want okay that's actually probably maybe
like the coolest answer and probably the
most right maybe yeah okay this is just
like so shocking to me I I pegged these
two as like a forever yeah me too and
it's still taking time for me to like
unlearn that my favorite is when like
someone breaks up and people go back and
find like certain videos and they're
like see
that's happening with Travis Kelsey this
video of him is going viral it's
actually from Watch What Happens Live
where he was asked like a bunch of
raunchy questions by Andy about sex
Ramona is the other guest and he
basically said like a deal breaker for
him is if a woman doesn't give oral sex
and Ramona's like slapping him being
like who raised you oh it's kind of
amazing I didn't know he had a dating
show oh my God you have to watch it no I
like that when I heard that too I was
like okay yeah I don't like it he has
actually recently ever he wasn't really
famous when that show came out so he was
just like a football player with a
reality show and now like last year he
got so famous and he was asked about and
he was like honestly like I know it's
weird but I was a rookie I had spent all
my money because like I was so excited
to be making money and I needed the
money and I actually respect the honesty
honestly that's why everyone's on
reality TV like at some point they were
like okay I'll do this for a paycheck no
and I I understand like being so young
and making money and blowing through it
like you're not thinking about fiscal
responsibility your first year in the
NFL so I actually understood it and you
should watch it I'm I think I'm gonna
and he ended up dating the girl that won
for like four or five months oh wow yeah
but she's the one who this week came out
and was like I'm a girls girl Taylor you
should know once a cheater always a
cheater she literally said that to the
Daily Mail so he cheated on her I guess
like eight years ago I mean and it was
like a relationship for TV so I actually
don't believe once a cheater always a
cheater you don't because I feel like
in call like okay in college there's
just like certain things that happen I
don't think like if you cheated in
college that means you're gonna like
cheat on your husband of 17 years no and
being young like is a thing right you're
young and moronic and that's fair no
like being young and stupid is very much
a thing but like a guy who's cheating on
his girlfriend and it's like a real
relationship and he's in his 30s like
you have problems right like if you're
living with your significant other and
you're like banging the secretary like
yeah
but like no if you're talking about a
relationship from like eight years ago
yeah that was four months long right I
don't think that equipped once a cheater
always a cheater so that's the Taylor
Swift update of the day now the
Kardashians are in the news actually
quite a bit today we have two stories
last night was the season premiere of
Kardashians on Hulu I know why did
nobody talk about that I had no idea
where is the marketing wait I'm livid no
last last season they sponsored the
toast so I knew when it wasn't so did
all of you yeah I had no idea
I didn't even know they there was
another season was coming out a trailer
came out a few weeks ago and it looked
good oh okay yes yes and then there was
no follow-up nothing but it actually was
like a crazy episode and the thing
everyone's talking about is this phone
call between Courtney and Kim okay it
was really bad so the timeline of this
it's important to know like where we're
at timeline yeah so the last season
they'd all just watched okay and So
Courtney saw the whole Dolce thing go
down she saw like Chloe and and Chris
and Courtney I mean and Kim in Milan
like toasting like that Courtney like
really bad yeah yeah yeah so tensions I
think are even worse okay and Courtney
is not on camera she's on the [__] Kim
is on the phone and you hear Courtney's
voice and it's just really bad like if
these two weren't sisters they would
never talk and honestly I'm always
inclined to take kit inside because up
until recently like Courtney really was
like so Miz all the time complaining
about her life and it was just like hard
to sympathize with this woman who you
know lives a life that seems perfect and
what are you always complaining about
Kimberly Noel Kardashian forever like I
don't care I love her and I will always
love her and I actually really respect
and like trust her I think up and like
no she's always trust her she's really
logical and she's not mean no and I feel
like she's actually for like who she is
and what's going on in her life yeah
down to earth yeah and she doesn't say
it right and she doesn't say it but on
this phone call like honestly I was not
on her side oh she goes so low so
basically she calls in and is like this
Dolce thing I'm still in the contract I
have to go back to Milan to do a dinner
I want to let you know and I also want
to invite you and Courtney's like
honestly I'm kind of dual shade out and
I just saw the episode like um to be
dolceed out that's kind of like life
goals yeah like for me currently right
now I'm kind of like targeted out I'm
just kind of like revolved out no I'm
Uber Eats by the way Uber Eats the [__]
out like Zara out like it's so hard for
us Paige like I'm so sorry about
but she's like I'm obviously not coming
to this dinner and Kim is like well like
we need to talk like you hate me yeah
yeah why
and Kim Courtney was just like honestly
after seeing this episode and just like
thinking about my wedding you came to my
wedding you were just clearly not happy
for me everyone told me you were
complaining the whole time did you watch
the wedding special I didn't I didn't
either so I feel like they didn't even
wouldn't allude to that I know special
which I wish they did so she goes
you weren't happy for me you were
complaining the whole time and then like
you come out and like do this Dolce
thing that's so similar to the vibe of
my wedding yeah when you couldn't maybe
I would have felt differently had you
been like you know jumping and dancing
at the wedding yeah but like this is
epic yeah she was like you just couldn't
stand that I was the center of attention
like you're a narcissist and like I had
a thing and you had to make it your
thing and honestly like I kind of feel
it I kind of feel it then it gets worse
Kim's like I don't know what you're
talking about I was so happy for you but
like we're all talking about how like
you're so different you seem so unhappy
in your life like all of your friends
text me and the family we have a chat
called not Courtney where everyone comes
to us to complain about you and
Courtney's like you're starting side
chats without me like you're the one
who's unhappy like I don't have side
chats about anyone like I'm living my
life yeah and then she said to me like
the most unforgivable thing like they're
just riling each other up yeah he has
remained so calm and I think it's like
making Courtney I can't even crazier yep
she goes I mean like even your kids have
come to me with problems
about how you are
Kimberly I know it's that's when I can
and Courtney didn't even give in she's
like all right you want to say that then
say that like sure now you're telling me
all my friends my kids and my family are
coming to you talking about me but I'm
the one who's unhappy like please and
she said on the kids thing is the only
thing that got Courtney choked up and at
the end she was like you're such a
[__] witch yeah and I [__] hate
you and hung up the phone oh my God it
was really bad I think last season they
hyped up a lot like Courtney vs Kim
Courtney versus Kim yeah but now it's
like it didn't really get that crazy
yeah this to me was the craziest
conversation that like makes me sad I
know and I feel like Courtney has had
like a tough
go of it in certain parts of like the
show and Kim is always like so beloved
that I'm kind of like justice for court
if this conversation had happened a few
years ago I'd be like yes finally
someone's saying that corny what's with
this mug on your face like yeah happy
you have a beautiful life like she was
kind of miss and I do think her life
turned around when she met Travis and I
really believe she's so happy I wonder
if they don't like Travis I
feel like they do I think he's such a
good step dad he's such a good dad to
his kids he's like kind of Ben sawfish
like he's very affable like everybody
who meets him loves him he's Travis
Barker celebrity I know and he loves
Courtney so like I don't know how you
couldn't be happy for yourself right
right when she's met someone who would
actually step in front of a train for
her like he loves her he's obsessed with
this conversation from court from Kim's
end feels misplaced to me like yeah I
don't feel like Courtney is so happy
obviously I don't know what's really
going on because I'm a nobody and they
like live but I wish we had the wedding
yeah I mean we do did you watch it no so
I like how we're like I wish we had the
wedding but we didn't even watch it but
I feel like they didn't allude to any
drama like I feel like it was supposed
to be like a home video Love Story yeah
I agree it was like directed by Ellen
Von unworth like she's not doing drama
she's doing like beautiful wedding but I
do always feel like Chris wanted
Courtney's wedding to be the way we
reacted to Sophia's and by the way I
think everyone loved it like it was
exciting seeing all the girls in Italy
and you know what I feel like that whole
like Dolce 90s like era that's now
popular it really was like started at
Courtney's wedding right all the girls
like for the Friday night and the
Saturday like the brunch all their
outfits like they were dressed by Delta
and they were sick yeah and Courtney Kim
made it a point to be like I didn't copy
like I told you I was telling everyone
at the wedding like I didn't like your
look I didn't like the vibe
so she's kind of validating what
Courtney's saying because Courtney was
like you were complaining the whole time
you weren't happy at my wedding and then
Kim was like I didn't copy I thought it
was ugly and it's just so sad say to
anyone yeah and also like I feel like
Chloe talked about on like a podcast or
something when she was like I wish you
wore like a different wedding dress I
did the Vanity Fair thing yes again and
lie detector and she was like do you
Courtney asked her did you like my
wedding dress
that was so mean no like I think there's
something to be said about like everyone
being like a little mean to Courtney and
I think there were many years where
maybe she would have deserved it because
she really was like a mean sister but
now in a reality taking a stance from a
reality TV Point
Courtney for so many years was the show
yeah like Courtney and Scott drama was
sometimes the only drama a season would
have so true we can't forget about the
years Courtney and Chloe Take Miami
where he punched the mirror I mean
iconic stuff and in the very beginning
the show really became so popular and
then Courtney got pregnant it was like
this crazy thing because Scott was like
so toxic like she she put the show on
her back for many years remember when
Courtney slept with that guy in Miami
um the friend what was his name sorry
remember when Courtney had a lesbian
experimenting phase and she made out
with that girl who then ended up on
Orange Is the New Black
she made out in the club with the girl
wait oh my God what do you want to take
Miami
I was so like I'm just like a little bit
Justice for Courtney I agree and that's
never something I thought I would say
and like the fact that she's like keeps
her marriage and her life like a little
bit private I get it because for so many
years you were on display bleeding out
like no you're right so okay I know it's
like shocking for me because I'm always
inclined to just like be team Kim same
but I honestly think like Courtney's
onto something yeah imagine Courtney
comes out with a spin-off show and it's
just her and Travis's life and like
we're just there's so much interesting
stuff there like
Travis at their blended family which is
always interesting Dynamics Alabama
Barker she's a star a star Mason Star
yep he's recently Bar Mitzvah Landon on
the Charlie Daniels show like it's just
so so much has happened and there's also
just really interesting family Dynamics
like you know Atiana his oldest daughter
yep it's actually not his biological
daughter it's his ex-wife's wife's
daughter with someone else and he raises
her oh I didn't realize that I thought
it was a different that was his daughter
a different mom no
so there's a lot going on no there's a
lot going on so there's there's internet
Shanna signed on well she's nuts
Courtney would never agree but she'd be
so good on reality TV for sure and she
would love it yeah today's episode is
also brought to you by Lululemon
specifically leggings from Lululemon
because I don't know if you've looked
outside recently but thank the lord it's
Sweater Weather Sweater Weather and that
means we're wearing our big sweaters
we're pairing them with leggings and
we're living our best lives comfortably
and we're getting our leggings at
Lululemon because they're the One Stop
Shop for leggings I just feel like you
know where would you go for the best
podcast you would go to the toast where
do you go for leggings you go to
Lululemon like it makes sense they have
a ton of different options here are like
some of the best ones the fast and free
leggings those ones are powered by new
Lux fabric it's really weightless on
your body it has great coverage and
those are designed for people who are
looking for a legging that gives them
complete freedom from distractions
whether you're running or jogging so if
you're super active we would definitely
recommend the fast and free leggings
they also have the Wonder train leggings
so it's designed with a really
Innovative fabric called everlux it's
their fastest drying fabric so it allows
you to work hard feel dry so that you
can effortly transition from sweat to
Street if you're also just a person who
runs hot which I am especially like in
my crevices I like a pair of leggings I
really share too much
um I like a pair of leggings that can
absorb moisture and not get cold because
if I'm sweating and then that patch of
sweat doesn't dry I'm like freezing in
my nether regions those are the Wonder
train leggings but by far I love the
Align leggings I love the whole align
collection from Lululemon but the Align
leggings are great if you're wearing
leggings not for active reasons like
you're just running errands or I love to
wear leggings on airplanes these ones
are so comfortable it's the nulu fabric
they have a lightweight low compression
yoga solution so it's versatile enough
for casual wear it's giving you like a
next to nothing body sensation and full
freedom of movement so get into the
Lululemon leggings at lululemon.com
that's
l-u-l-ulemon.com today's episode is also
brought to you by e-boost so if you are
looking for a boost of energy they are
the sponsor of today's show and I have
to tell you uh they are a fabulous
product especially for me because I
don't love coffee but them you know
sometimes I get tired like even
podcasters get tired and here's what's
so great about e-boost they're non-GMO
soy free and vegetarian plus gluten-free
they contain no artificial flavors
colors or sweeteners and they have 15
calories or less per can including only
one to two grams of sugar so they're
made with high quality ingredients and
they're great if you're just looking for
like everyday energy if you're having a
late night you're working or studying
through the night like they always do on
suits they're up all night I don't know
how they're doing it without e-boost
um if you work out it's really good for
before after your workout if you're
suffering from jet lag like you took a
red eye or for me like that 3pm slump
that's always when I reach for an
e-boost drink
that to me is like the hardest time of
day and the most important you know we
still have a few hours left in the day
you know we have the same hours in a day
as Beyonce so don't be feeling tired at
3 P.M take the Super fuel from e-boost
it's only 10 calories a can it's
formulated with vitamins minerals
antioxidants nootropics it's not what
you'd normally expect in an energy drink
and when you compare it to some other
popular energy drinks you would be Shook
at like the sugar intake the calories
all of those things so of course we have
a great deal for you guys they're so
confident that you're going to love
super fuel they are giving you a four
pack for free all you have to do is pay
for the shipping so take advantage of
this offer today when you go to
ebboost.com toast to get your free four
pack of super fuel today's episode is
also brought to you by the farmer's dog
so the stress Brethren are the most
important people in our lives and if you
have a stress bro in your life you know
how important it is to take care of
their whole body health and switching to
fresh healthy food like the farmer's dog
is going to make such a difference in
your dog's day to day and also just like
increase the longevity of your dog's
life like that's what we're here to do
take care of our Stripes Brethren
because very sadly they can take care of
themselves
so switching to from kibble to Fresh can
seem like magic when a senior dog starts
acting like a puppy again and the
pickiest of eaters can't wait for dinner
time you might think some spells were
cast but the farmer's dog doesn't use
any sorcery or secret ingredients to
make their food fresh it's just science
they are making and delivering fresh
healthy dog food it's developed by vets
it's nutritionally balanced and it's
made from real healthy ingredients to
human foods food safety conditions it is
really the best option for dogs at all
life stages because it's not kibble it's
not canned crap it's just real healthy
food
the farmer's dog isn't just fresh high
quality food they also send the food
pre-portioned specifically for your dog
based on their unique nutritional needs
so when you sign up they'll ask you a
ton of questions about your dog so that
when your packages arrive you know
exactly what you're giving them is
exactly what would be recommended
there's so many benefits like Theo when
he switched his breath was such a
problem for me like it was not normal
dog breath it was bad better breath
shinier coat more energy his poops are
more consistent just so many things
because he's really like healthier now
like whole body health
Theo's on a fitness journey as well so
get 50 off your first box of fresh
healthy food at the farmersdog.com toast
plus you get free shipping but only when
you go to the farmersdog.com toast
that's the farmersdog.com toast to get
50 off your first box and free shipping
all right our second Kardashian story is
another plot line from the episode last
night but it's not nearly as serious
Kris Jenner forced her boyfriend Corey
Gamble to reject a role on Yellowstone
so Kris Jenner revealed during the
season for premiere of the Kardashians
that she once blocked her longtime
boyfriend Corey Gamble from appearing in
the hit Paramount show Yellowstone
Jenner claimed that she forced Corey to
turn down the role in the Kevin
costner-led series when she learned that
the role might contain some romantic
scenes the Revelation came while the
matriarch and her two daughters Chloe
and Kim grabbed dinner with Corey and
Cabo she said I'm so excited to watch
the next episode of Yellowstone and
Corey said well if it wasn't for you I
would be a Yellowstone star confused as
to why someone wouldn't take the
opportunity to be on camera Kim asked
Corey why he turned on such a prominent
role
and Chris butted in and she said because
I thought he was going to have a
romantic relationship
unable to resist the urge to poke fun at
her mom Chloe lassit herself into the
conversation but if they said they
wanted you to Star and kiss Kevin
Costner I'm sure you would take it I'm
shocked I'm shocked it also kind of
feels like this is an ad for Yellowstone
like in the Kardashians does it not
right product placement they did a great
job no I know even though like
Yellowstone
um is like not in production Kevin
Costner won't film and they like haven't
it was like they and they did a
mid-season finale I hate when this
happens with shows it's been over a year
since the mid-season finale so season
five never even ended
oh my God yeah yeah Kevin Costner like
won't you up for work Kev he's also
going through divorce so it's like not
helping
and his wife wants like 300 000 a month
and she doesn't want to work and
relatable no I love that for her and
also like didn't she like sleep with his
best friend like there's like a lot
going on and he has like this 40 million
dollar it kind of looks like Yellowstone
like Ranch I'd love if they had a
reality show yes okay I'm shocked at
Kris Jenner I know I feel like she above
all like knows a good opportunity when
she sees it right and like what Corey
was gonna like go then like be with this
woman like that makes me think more is
going on between her and Corey and maybe
let's put that that shot I want to say
like yeah this sounds like someone who's
insecure but if Ben got offered a role
where he had to kiss someone like I'm
out I'm out no way unless it was gonna
make him like really really famous okay
it's funny because Craig always will say
like also none of us are actors I know
but at least hypotheticals every couple
have this conversation I know yes they
do
Craig was like look if we like agreed
like it's just acting and it was for
your career like fine but I like would
feel a certain type of way and I would
feel nothing I feel like if Craig did it
yeah well here's the thing like what am
I getting out of there so let's say Ben
is booked to roll on a TV show is it
like a very minor role where he doesn't
come back then it's not worth it right
is it gonna shoot me him and our family
to stardom yeah I'm all for it okay got
it like the the benefits have to
outweigh the risks but you what are the
risks that you think that like Ben would
fall in love with this girl that he
kissed one time and is Gonna Leave You
for like this random actress what if
it's like some shiksa goddess then it's
like you know so
tantalized by her blonde hair an
enormous perky breasts I I just don't
see
Ben saw for celebrity doing that to his
family well you know Ben hosts a podcast
with Josh Peck yeah and I whenever I'm
on their podcast I'm always asking him
because he's an actor like he's kissed a
bunch of different people I think he
look just kissed Hilary Duff like in his
show I'm like what like how yeah and
he's like it's just not like that it's
actually like weird like so many people
are watching you you're literally acting
and it's kind of like weird and gross
like it's not good can I tell you
something
because you're a book girly when I was
in high school I had to do a commercial
for a James Patterson book oh we have to
find that it's called Uh I forget what
it was called they were like we were
like vampires I want to say or something
[__] way I'm 16 years old I'm
literally harnessed up I have to like
fly through the air make out scene oh
kissed a guy had a boyfriend in high
school my mom's like on set with me
because I'm a child
I fell in love with this man
fully fell in love with him every so
often I'll look him up on the Internet
no [__] way was he married what's he
up to uh I haven't looked in years last
time I looked him up actually has
probably been like five years ago but I
had just moved to New York City saw him
on the street did he recognize you we
both recognized each other for sure but
we both didn't say hi kept walking but I
was like oh my God that was definitely
the guy I made out with oh and I don't
think he recognized me because like I
was 16 and then he was seeing me I was
like 25. right
how crazy so was your boyfriend mad at
the time he was like a little yeah he
was like almost like everyone's like
making fun of me and I was like it's
literally a job like Get over I have a
similar story like not really when I was
like just starting out influencing I had
like maybe like 500 000 followers on
Instagram I got reached out to by The
Steve Harvey Show it was like my first
time ever being on TV like for an
interview and I was like oh [__] yes yes
I was so excited and the more I talked
to the producer they were like we're
making it a dating segment okay and it
was like you have to judge like because
we want to learn all about social media
like you're going to see three boys
social media profiles Okay and like
judge them and then like choose one okay
and I was like oh yeah I'm single for
sure Ben's like literally next to me Ben
comes with me to Chicago yeah like look
alike everybody just thought we were
like brother and sister I'm like this is
my brother
and I literally had to do this dating
segment where like literally three
different guys yeah and I like chose one
and Ben was like trying to be happy for
me he was having a mental breakdown in
the dressing room like losing his
[__] mind I mean you don't have to
like make out then did you like hang out
with them after no they had to film a
little segment where we like walking to
a restaurant like on a fake date wait I
love this it was like a resurface that
no we don't don't you dare and it was
like a seafood restaurant just that I
need to hire some company to get that
scrubbed from the internet like I love
that
um next story my favorite couple to talk
about Lauren Sanchez says there's
nothing better than seeing her fiance
Jeff Bezos
um yeah I would be excited again yeah
like just to be with him like yeah I'd
be excited too if every time my fiance
came to see me he brought me like a 40
million dollar house I'd love to see
anyone on their yacht yeah like you
could bring my arch nemesis and I'd be
like it's great running into you I would
be like move over yeah let's go so even
a whole day apart is too long for these
lovebirds Lauren Sanchez couldn't help
but gush over her soon to be hubby Jeff
Bezos in a heartfelt post on social
media she said nothing better than when
I get to see him for lunch between his
meetings it wasn't long before fans and
celebs rushed to like to the comment
section cute Kyle Richards wrote
meanwhile pop star Katy Perry who shares
a close friendship with the couple also
responded with a heart emoji this woman
is the luckiest woman in America I'm the
luckiest woman in America I also just
really like weirdly like them as a
couple even though I don't like die for
Jeff Bezos or anything even though he
has changed my life
um I feel like of all the girls he could
have dated like after divorcing his wife
he could have dated like an 18 year old
and everybody would have been like okay
he dated someone age appropriate I do
find it respectful yeah they've really
been together I feel like they're like
an oddly traditional courtship even
though the way that they came out as a
couple was weird with like remember her
brother who wasn't she married yeah and
like her brother was like selling their
sex to the National Enquirer and we saw
all those text messages of him being
like I want to drink with you like not
get drunk but just like a little tipsy
and then like wake up with you and read
the newspaper
he didn't say like I want to clap those
cheeks [__]
it was really there's something about
when you say something really funny and
sexual like it hits so different like
specifically yeah like I think it's ten
times funnier because I'm not like that
like I don't yeah like someone else
could have said slap those cheeks I
would have been like it's a little
vulgar but when you say it like also I
don't know oddly like cute I don't know
if like slap those cheeks or something I
think it's clap those teeth oh whatever
um I just like I weirdly think they're
sweet and they had like a traditional
courtship they were like dating for like
a year and a half got engaged like it's
like a normal people does she have kids
I
don't know he must I think he does but I
just like I don't know why I think about
it from the point of like if I was her
daughter like how happy I would be like
my bat mitzvah would be the event of the
sanctuary yeah Mom [__] Dad it's also so
different it's funny how different
Mackenzie Bezos his ex-wife and uh Jeff
like live and spend their money yeah she
got 36 billion dollars I think she gave
35 and a half of it to like a million
different charities and now like lives a
life of poverty with her half a billion
dollars yeah and he I think is now worth
like a hundred billion dollars he has
not given one dollar away he's going to
space No it's it's just funny how men
and women are different like yeah and I
do I do always get annoyed maybe
different because he they're not like
famous actors or something but like I
always think of Chris Pratt and Anna
Faris like I think about it a lot and
that's so funny I never think about them
but they're people worth thinking about
I think about them a lot because when
they got together she was very popular
probably the height of her career yeah
rom-com Queen he was like a little
chubby and he was on TV yeah and no he
had like that very small role in that
terrible movie Five-Year Engagement and
it was just and then all of a sudden
rules reversed and he was like oh and by
the way I'm out yeah and I'm a star now
I'm skinny bye and she loved him while
he was no one and I think about it a lot
and it really annoys me so when anything
comes up about him in pop culture and
people are like so for him I'm like I
didn't forget you know who I have that
same thing with Austin Butler and
Vanessa Hudgins
she saw something again that nobody saw
she told she discovered him she told him
to be Elvis she was dating him when he
was on The Carrie Diaries the CW amazing
show by the way prequel to The Sex and
the City like she was with him during
the dark times The Carrie Diaries was so
good and people don't talk about it
enough nobody talks about it it's the
most incredible show it has really
nothing to do with sex in the city
because Carrie Carrie was not like that
girl no no no no the Anna Sophia Rob
crushed the role of Carrie crushed it
was the best show and that's like
literally all he did after his like
Nickelodeon Fame and then he was just
like famous for being like a former
Child Star and being really hot and
dating Vanessa Hudgens yeah and then he
became a star and never once saw or
spoke to her again like that pisses me
off and now he's like engaged to Kaya
Gerber I just watched a movie last night
on Amazon called bottoms and Kaya Gerber
was in it I heard it was great me and
Craig loved it I heard it was amazing I
want to watch it it's like very odd and
like things were happening and we were
like what are we watching but for
whatever reason we were like this is
amazing and I can't and she's in it as
like an actress
yes and she is so good wow and I think
it was because she's not like a main
main right she's a little bit Supporting
Cast but she definitely has lines and I
think it was a great way to like intro
her into movies and I have nothing
against her I think she makes a nice
couple but I have something against him
yeah I feel like he's a little arrogant
Jackie like put it into my brain she's
like I think he's a social climber and
now I can only see that him is that yes
he is I also like when he gave up to
give a speech got up and he was like
full accent of that the accent thing was
I think threw a lot of people off it's
it was too much I just I never forget
Vanessa Hudgens just like you never
forget Yeah Anna Faris and how he won't
ever say Vanessa's name
that like yeah that she she was the one
who gave him the idea to pursue a role
in Elvis she was like your voice like
you can sing like him Justice for
[__] but she's really happy giving
anyone that nice of a compliment never
in my life I'm like Ben you should play
Both of the clown
in his biopic no I feel like I called
Craig like Ellen DeGeneres the other day
you know like no I call Ben Bose of the
clown whenever he puts on like a crazy
outfit he's always wanting to experiment
I'm like just wear black pants yeah but
he's always had to put on like yeah in a
very experimental face and I said okay
Bozo yeah
look that's well now he knows like he'll
put an outfit on and he'll come in and
before he even asks he's like bozo
it's adorable no I know at first he was
offended but I'm like listen I I want
what's best for you yeah I'm trying to
help I'm out here helping you our fifth
and final story is probably one of my
favorite sagas in pop culture that
nobody is talking about okay I'm sure
everybody knows that Katy Perry is like
in this crazy lawsuit
nobody's talking about it thank you
she's in this crazy lawsuit over a piece
of real estate that she had purchased
from this like very old man he's a
former he's a veteran and he was he had
just gotten back surgery he was on crazy
like opioids and they presented him with
a legal document and he signed it and
then two days later when he came to he
was like wait I just signed away my
house I live here I don't want to sell
it and now they're in a crazy lawsuit
she's suing him for Millions which is
okay it's crazy but what makes the Saga
crazier is that this man do you want to
know who his daughter is yeah who
Cameron Westcott from The Real
Housewives of Dallas it's her dad
yes yes all the roads lead back to Bravo
that's crazy also Katy Perry in Orlando
also wait side note I just saw Orlando
blooms in like a new movie I saw like
the preview for it on the TV he looks
Horrible no have you ever seen his penis
I personally haven't I have because he
got Paparazzi um nude paddle boarding in
like Mallorca or something and tiny
small I just think he's a grower he
wasn't like it wasn't a Rex on the
paddle board right he was just chilling
um she must have great PR that like not
that many people are speaking about this
is also the second like major lawsuit
she had sued this like Coventry like a
covenant like what's it called a
covenant okay where like where nuns live
a Convent Convent yeah I'm so dumb she
had sued like a Convent because like she
wanted their land and then like these
old nuns like died and it was like a
whole thing
um um wait small Katy Perry story yeah
so one time I was doing an Amazon live
and she had a shoe line that was like
exclusive Amazon yeah she has like a
what's it called like kitty kitty shoes
or something and I was doing the live
with her and I was so nervous so like
the night before I memorized all of the
shoes and like their names were so that
like we could just like say the name of
the shoe and then blah blah blah blah
she was so late that like they were so
nervous about it that we couldn't even
do we were supposed to do like a
rehearsal didn't do a rehearsal she just
like came in and it was virtual oh and
I'm
sweating and I'm saying the name we're
doing the live I'm saying the names of
the shoes and she was like I have no
idea what you're told
like she didn't know the names of the
shoes so then I was like did I just
insult her by like making knowing more
Yeah by like making her almost look bad
so then I couldn't say the name she
threw it out the window yeah I threw it
up but no okay so here's the update on
the Lego battle she's slammed for quote
attacking the week by the family of
diring dying veteran Carl Westcott she
is suing for 2.6 million dollars in
property dispute as his son is saying
his American hero father shouldn't have
to spend his last days fighting her in
court so honestly I'm not really
interested in the details of the legal
battle what I'm interested in is another
thing I learned about this man ready
you're saying oh how can Cameron
westcott's how can this war veteran own
a property for 15 million dollars that
Katy Perry wants to buy like you don't
get paid to be in the Army right more
importantly do you know what he did
after the Army what he is the founder
and this is how Cameron Westcott is so I
know this is how Cameron West got so
rich
he is the founder of 1-800 Flowers
oh
isn't that crazy oh my God so at this
point it's like rich people fighting
rich people like I don't really care but
like let's see so he can he can afford
yes to pay the loss but it's more so
that he's like in hospice like leave
this man alone yeah that's crazy but I
just think it's fascinating that that's
what her fortune and then she you know
she married very well so Cameron
westcott's doing just fine post real
housewives in Dallas
I did it was good because our production
company actually that may make summer
house made Dallas got it I think like
they deserved uh more no there was
Brandi had a lot to give and they didn't
they didn't execute it yeah they didn't
explore it same with Leanne locken no
she had to be fired for a multitude of
reasons and I agree with them but we
would be lying if we sat here and said
she wasn't a star
they're just hand her boyfriend that
worn eye patch oh yeah what was the same
Rick he was a cop I mean just no TV gold
TV gold is this moment
season one episode one okay we meet all
the women
besides Leanne yeah and they're all
talking about Leanne they say Leanne
she's the woman to know Leanne you want
to be on her good side she runs this
town yeah it's all these millionaire
women with their Chanel bags millionaire
Leanne we're afraid of Leanne cut to
Leanne we show we see her for the first
time I remember my jaw dropped that
there's anything wrong but she lives in
this like tiny house yeah and I'm like
why are all these incredibly
well-connected Rich 1-800 Flowers women
yep why are they afraid what power does
she have yeah they're like in the
charity world it's Leanne Lankan I'm
like oh I can't wait to see Leanne's
house I'm like let's go I'm like it's
just a regular house I was floored that
was like a jaw-dropping moment and I
found out later that because the pilot
of Real Housewives of Dallas wasn't
supposed to be real housewives of Dallas
it was supposed to be a show about like
wealthy women in Dallas but all about
like the charity World okay and that's
why every other word on the first
episode of Real Housewives of Dallas is
Charity yeah charity this charity that
I'm like charity no literally I felt so
bad I was like it's enough we got it
it's nice like I know that's what rich
women do they do yeah for sure but
that's not what the Real Housewives is
about maybe one yeah maybe once every
season there's a charity event right but
that's not the point right like we have
enough homeless toothless
like we get it yeah like in New Jersey
they have dolores's annual baseball game
to raise money for breast cancer which
is amazing no we love that in Beverly
Hills they have homeless not Toothless
and in New York Housewives the old one
they had that woman who like lived in a
shelter and Ramona and Sonia wouldn't
let her get a word in and they forgot
her name that was the best moment of my
life her name was like um birdie or
something
yeah that was that's an iconic moment
that people don't replay it it's not a
popular enough one but actually a friend
of mine over like the court last last
year has been like wanting to get into
Bravo so she watched Beverly Hills and
she's like what should I watch next I'm
like you have to watch New York yeah and
she keeps sending me the clips of her TV
of like mostly Alex McCord moments and
honestly I'm getting such an itch I need
she's at the party New York City is
unparalleled she's at the part where
Alex McCord is like taking her modeling
career really seriously and she's doing
like hip-hop dance classes to just like
learn to be in music video sets I need
to re-watch it Simon also was the love
of my life he was too
like too good for his time like they
weren't appreciated in their own time
and I saw somebody tweet once like
recently that if Alex and Simon McCord
were on right now they would be so well
liked because they were like edgy
Brooklyn they're like we don't need to
live in Manhattan but like in the early
2000s we're like no you need to live in
Manhattan yeah and like and now Brooklyn
is like so nice and they would be so
popular now but I re-watched like the
early two three seasons during covid and
I forgot that they were living in this
like actual construction dungeon like
Jill comes over and she's like you're
living in this like it was actually
Luanne says like her shoes are like
Herman Munster shoes that's a little bit
later she's like oh is that a buffalo
coming down the stairs
you came down in your Herman mustard
shoes uh they were Louis Vuitton well
even Louis Vuitton makes them like she
was so iconic remember when she um
yelled at Bethany for
not making her chauffeur call Bethany
Mrs Frankel she lets the chauffeur call
her Bethany no she was like actually
awful when she was like dinner Alex
Luanne okay Luanne they get to get into
a car with like this driver who Bethany
knows and he's calling her Bethany yes
yes yes and she's like Bethany you
should really be calling you Mrs Frankel
my favorite was when she went to Miami
and she went to go look at a poster of
herself like and none of the other women
she was in her hustle era then because
she was no longer married she was
rebuilding like a business she was going
on tour and her tour actually ended up
in like extremely successful she's
playing like big theaters and yeah and
she was like a little full of herself
but you know what she every write to me
she was like a woman scorned and she was
out on her own you know hustling for a
dollar for her family they did an
episode like where did the housewives
come from like in like their chest hers
was actually impressed fascinating and
extremely impressive like the things she
had accomplished modeling like living
different places and very yeah like a
go-getter yeah no you're right like
there's more to these women but there's
like a few women especially from New
York who I just identify with like I
love like Luanne could never do anything
that would make me dislike her yeah I
just I ride for her yeah I love Luanne
but so back to Cameron Westcott like I
just think not enough people know that
the man Katy Perry is doing is Cameron
westcott's dad and he uh founded 1-800
Flowers I just think that was
information everybody yeah more people
should be talking about this that's what
we do but that's why you're our leader
that's what we do here at the toast page
oh my God this has been such a long
episode Paige thank you so much for
being here thank you for having me if
you enjoyed what you heard here which I
can't imagine you didn't listen to
Paige's podcast she hosted with Hannah
burner it's called giggly Squad and it's
just it's a giggle yeah it is it's
really happening over there and if
you're inspired by Pages just overall
fabulosity follow her on Instagram I
want to see Paige underscore disorder
yeah why not what happened what's with
the underscore this by the way whenever
there's a guest on at the end I'm like
promoting them and then I grill them for
their handles I'm like why space
um I did a space because at the time
when I made my Instagram I thought like
oh this is easier to read why because
you think it would be paged or Sorbo
yeah like I didn't know if people were
gonna well it's working together you
have a ton of followers so make sure to
follow her and thank you guys so much
for listening to the toast tomorrow's
episode is Jackson Claude video and
audio so we'll see you then thank you so
much for listening to The Chosen Monday
Morning Show where we deliver the fast
five stories that you need to know
everybody through Friday on YouTube so
if you're watching this on YouTube
please feel free to subscribe and give
video a thumbs up if you're also
available as a podcast anywhere
podcasting you found so Spotify to
Sister public radio I already castbox
all the places web deals in a podcast
find us the Chelsea the five star review
[__] about how beautiful stunning and
wickedly talented we are have an amazing
Thursday and we'll see you tomorrow for
Friday woohoo that's my favorite part I
know have you ever seen on Tick Tock
where that one crazy oh are we done I
have to say bye
I thought you were still talking